then Casey will not be seen this evening
so that we may bring you the 37th annual
awards of the Academy of Motion Picture
Arts and Sciences then Casey will be
seen next week at its regularly
scheduled time over most of these ABC
television stations
live from Santa Monica California the
annual Academy Awards
the Academy of Motion Picture Arts and
Sciences invite you to be its guests at
the 37th annual awards presentation yeah
them kinetic policies at an all-time
finance every five minutes the best
daily the Dick Van Dyke and mrs. Van Wyk
one of the exciting highlights of Oscar
night has always been the arrival of
prominent motion picture personalities
from Hollywood this day Jonathan winters
is now arriving let's have a big welcome
for mr. mrs. Jonathan winters ladies and
gentlemen to Dick Van Dyke jack once
again man the chamber I fair lady
accompanied by Miss John Marshall thank
you
and this is durable magnificent Agnes
Moorehead a nominee this year as Best
Supporting Actress for her role in hush
hush sweet Charlotte this greer garson
perpetually lovely miss Carson appearing
tonight as awards presenter and Margaret
together with Roger Smith
and scurry received a tremendous boost
by her appearance seeing one of the
nominated saw elegant Deborah Carr
frequent Academy nominee
mr. Anthony Quinn for Best Actor nominee
for his performance in the survey the
Greek also a past Academy winner George
Hamilton did we ask you to come up a
lovely Lila Catawba a nominee for any
order the Greek also and welcome to
sunny Southern California actress being
interviewed here by mr. army Archerd
this is Jane Fonda accompanying Jane
Raja buddy we're going to be seeing you
soon in Cat Ballou right we look forward
thanks very much
Miss Jane Fonda mr. Roger Vadim ladies
and gentlemen not another representative
from the medical field mr. Vince Edwards
and now the overture played by
academy-award orchestra conducted by
four-time Academy Award winner John
Green
well
ladies and gentlemen the president of
the Academy of Motion Picture Arts and
Sciences mr. Arthur freed
I think it is safe to say that we live
in troubled times if the motion picture
can lay claim to anything that is this
it provides us a short vacation for my
troubles for a few moments slow and
Maury a replace with some mirth some
music and an occasional density for a
moment of insight that uplifts our
spirits this shows an annual salute to
the men and women of every country who
make these motion pictures this evening
is a particularly pleasing one for many
of us forgive because we have as I guess
some of the treasured stars of earlier
years now to the business at hand I
would like you to meet mr. Bill Miller
of Price Waterhouse company the ballot
have been counted
a certificate that Pricewaterhouse is
tabulated the ballots and results when
he's on words thank you well now it's my
privilege to introduce our master of
ceremonies a man who needs no
certification for the position in as
much as this is his 12th appearance for
the Academy no man has done more to
represent Hollywood of his finest to
America in the world than the splendid
gentleman mr. Bob Hope
Hey
Thank You Arthur thank you ladies and
gentlemen good evening and welcome to
Santa Monica on the Thames
well here we go again it's envy time and
I'm your host the Jolly Green MC this
will be a very unusual night tonight
Hollywood is handing out the 40's
tonight we come to you from Santa Monica
on the shores the beautiful blue Pacific
for the chosen few the waters will pause
for the rest of us its beloved globe now
this is a great moment for the film
industry the night movies come into the
room to think I might not have known
about it if I hadn't read it in TV god
this means a lot to everyone in the
movie industry this is the night wars
and politics are forgotten and we find
out who we really hate see they're out
there the nominees when they turn the
cameras around it looks like a rerun of
profiles in courage this is our night
the night that separates the men from
the boys the weak the strong and the
actress and their agents
so the suspense here is fabulous and all
the praying there's so many prayers
being spoken up right now we could
export to the Yuka Medical Council
thousands of voices saying silently let
it be me but if it can't be me not him
incidentally this show is coming to you
live no matter how I may look in this
suit
at least is deductible the internal
revenue of Europe check the results of
my 20 years attending the awards and we
decided that for me it's a benefit and
tonight makes me a two-time loser
because due to some repair work on
Hollywood Boulevard my star is now a
manhole cover
I don't mind losing but I hate to go
home and explain to my kids how the
actors I've been sneering at all year
beat me out over also pre-empting father
Crosby tonight which isn't good I hate
to give him an excuse to go home he
thinks there's an award for the most
short subjects but this is a big year
this year moviemaking is more important
than ever a hit movie can make an
airline 65 was a big year for the movie
this was the year lovely Julie Andrews
made a motion picture debut in the big
hit called Mary Poppins or Mary Poppins
or how I learned to stop worrying and
love Jack Warner this was the year one
of our stars George Murphy went to the
Senate a great victory for the Late Show
and 20th Century Fox made a deal with
Notre Dame they're changing the title
their picture to Monsignor Goldfarb
please come home
this is also a time to review the
accomplishments of the last year was a
year in which a man made a biblical
picture in the United States and was
accused by the European studios of
runaway production
it was also the year Otto Preminger ran
out of religions Darryl zanuck almost
ran on awards but mostly it was a year
of great achievements they made a
picture called Fanny Hill they thought
it was about mountain climbing
incidentally there's a new rule tonight
before you can pick up your Oscar you
have to show your passport
12 all the 20 acting nominations went to
foreigners but we're not worried
we still lead the world in the
production of popcorn how do you like
those nominations Richard Burton Rex
Harrison Peter O'Toole Peter Sellars
don't we deport anybody there'll always
be in England even if it's in Hollywood
Peter Sellers who played three parts in
dr. Strangelove was nominated for Best
Performance by a show-off Sophia Loren
got nominated for Marriage italian-style
- documentary marriage italian-style is
sort of a Peyton Place with marinara
sauce my fair lady was good if you like
foreign language pictures
dr. Strangelove is about a doctor them
has a strange love he wants Medicare in
Beckett Richard Burton plays the most
unusual role of his career he's friends
with a man
Burton doesn't even know he's been
nominated yet the phone still off the
hook
then there's over the Greek I knew he do
big things if he got a haircut I
understand they're already working on
the sequel is over the Greek it's called
hush-hush virus courts but this is a
wonderful year you know last year
pictures were so dirty you either got an
Oscar or summons but this is the year
the Sanitary cinema the nominations are
so devoid of dirt the best producer
award may go to mr. clean Mary Poppins
is so clean adults can go and see it and
incidentally they tuned in at Cape
Kennedy the night of the Unsinkable
Molly Brown wins Grissom and young will
blast off and buzz the auditorium in
their capsule well we're going out of
the reading of the will
oh by the way later on tonight we're
going to take up a collection to help
President Johnson pay his taxes
he'd ever think he'd turn out to be a
private in the war on poverty now let's
get to the agony and the ecstasy our
awards here to make the first
presentation of two of the screens most
dynamic stars that beautiful work of
idol a charming are Claudia Cardinale
and to protect your America's three
fisted Steve McQueen right here
see what do you mean we fisted well it's
just a joke Claudia you see Bob the
comedian no one everyone was laughing at
him what do we do now well we read the
list of nominees for the best
achievement in sound ladies first
the nominees are Shepperton studios
sound the patent for Becky Universal
City Studios sound department for father
good why Disney studio sound the fabula
for Mary Poppins Warner Brothers Studios
sound department for my fair lady
network or email your studio sound
Department for the unsecured bond with
Molly Brown the envelope please
you other Steve you have three feet
and the winner is Warner Brothers my
fair lady
Kuchar on behalf of Warner Brothers
sound department I thank you very much
I'd like to pay special tribute to mr.
Francis Scheid who did the production
recording and to mr. Murray Spivak with
a fine job of recording the fair lady
music thank you very much